fishes Eddie is a local independent
kitchenware store they make delightful
plates featuring New York skyline but
this week they run into some unexpected
trouble with the government agency last
week a Port Authority attorney fired off
a letter to fish's Eddy according to the
letter your use of the Port Authority's
assets on dinnerware and other items is
of great concern to the Port Authority
the store was also told the use of the
images interferes with the Port
Authority's control of its own
reputation that's right
that's right the Port Authority is
anxious to protect its reputation and
here is something the port authority
clearly does not understand its
reputation is terrible because the only
thing people think of when they hear its
name is the Port Authority Bus Terminal
also known as the single worst place on
planet Earth it is a place it's a place
where cockroaches run up to people
screaming please get me out of here this
place is disgusting the Port Authority
is so famously awful that the sitcom
Everybody Hates Chris once had an
episode called everybody hates the Port
Authority which featured this scene hey
I want y'all to be real careful in here
this place is full of pickpockets pimps
and and thieves
that's the Port Authority slogan and the
producers were safe in the knowledge
that everyone would understand that joke
because you do not need to have been to
the Port Authority to know that you
never want to go there
and yet the Port Authority is worried
that a whimsical plate will destroy its
reputation well well look if they really
want to take ownership of their
hard-earned image maybe we can be of
some help New York home to such icons as
the Empire State Building the Statue of
Liberty and of course the Port Authority
Bus Terminal the Big Apple's magnificent
Warren if you really want to know the
Port Authority's reputation just ask any
New Yorker for the
it was pretty gross I think it's
disgusting kind of fuzzy it really
creeps me out kind of like a dumpy
from the eighties and in
tribute to this great building we're
proud to introduce the official Port
Authority dinner plates handcrafted from
Port Authority bathroom tiles the plate
features all the most famous Port
Authority sites an old woman throwing up
in a garbage man an unattended child all
right orgy
a man relieving himself into a water
fountain a used condom and three loose
teeth and two pregnant woman fist
fighting the official Port Authority
dinner plate eat